hey what is up guys MKBHD here quick
plug so the merch store is actually back
open right now and this is the run you
got to get in on if you want to get your
stuff shipped in time for the holidays
for getting stuff for friends family
that kind of thing and there's actually
some new items there's some long sleeves
since it's getting cold there's some
stickers and we got a little bit of a
Black Friday surprise and coming for you
too so definitely stay tuned for that
it's gonna be Joe
[Music]
all right so today we got a few
headphones in front of me and they're
all wireless headphones so you've
probably heard me at some point in the
past year of videos say smartphones
losing a headphone jack but it doesn't
really bother me anymore because I've
been living that wireless life I'm
reviewing and using and living with
these phones year after year for like
the past two years all these new phones
keep coming out with no headphone jack
so you just kind of have to get on that
train so to help it be less painful for
you I got a couple of my favorite
wireless headphones in front of me these
are all good certified tested I like
them so first off you may have seen that
tweet a couple days or weeks ago
praising these Microsoft Surface
headphones that I started using over the
bows that I've been using for years
little skepticism on that but these are
the real deal now the bows are still
great don't get me wrong at 349 Bucks
ever since I reviewed them a long time
before I've even had them they've been
the industry standard for a noise
cancellation Solid Audio quality but
it's the awesome noise cancellation and
pretty much anyone who can fly with
these will do that including me until
last week so these surface headphones
came out they are the same price still
very premium but I definitely like them
now more than the Bose for that money
for a couple reasons first off is the
build now they're still mostly
lightweight Plastics but these have this
soft touch feel all the way around the
headband and the ear cups are super soft
and they just look more modern and clean
all the way around like the rest of the
surface products this little yoke angle
is a small detail but it makes a big
difference the way they sit on your head
and they completely envelop the ear
they're totally over it instead of on it
and it's just more comfortable and that
makes a big difference for people
sitting on a six hour flight that goes a
long way the inputs and outputs are also
a bit more modern so USB type c now for
charging instead of micro USB and
there's a microphone mute button and
every time you turn it on a voice now
says how many hours of battery left
instead of your percent and it seemed to
get the full 30 to 40 hours you'd expect
which is nice that's Cortana at work and
then the dials okay so instead of a plus
or minus volume button on the side that
you're feeling for the whole side of the
headphone is this is dial on actually
both sides on the right side is just
volume up or volume down and on the left
side it's adjusting your level of noise
cancellation so turning it all the way
forward is turning on full noise
cancellation and all the way back is all
the way off plus there's an extra level
that actually starts to amplify Ambient
sound it's like the opposite of noise
cancellation and it's really interesting
actually how well these work so when you
have them in amplify mode you put them
on it sort of cancels the effect of the
passive noise cancellation so without it
you just wouldn't hear much but with it
on you'd ideally like in a work
environment if someone called your name
you'd actually be able to hear it over
the music so that's decent and then as
you turn it towards noise cancellation
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
gradient I would just kind of have it
all the way off or all the way on but as
you turn it all the way on you'll start
to see and hear sounds around you
disappear so if someone's talking
directly to you as you're turning the
dial you'll hear their voice get quieter
and quieter until as you get
it nice and then these are kind of
acting like smart headphones too they
have a mic the audio is paired if you
long hold the side panel it activates
whatever Voice Assistant you have
Microsoft prefers Cortana you can get
Cortana for Android or iOS if you want
but I never really worried about that it
works perfectly fine with Google
assistant and it works with Siri it's
kind of like a cherry on top so these
are my new go-to flight headphones and
just casual listening headphones they're
not the best audio Fidelity in the world
I mean they're Wireless first of all and
then they're a little weaker in the mids
and the highs than the bows were but
just as far as Bluetooth streaming over
Spotify these are more than fine they
sound pretty good and they're just that
much more comfortable okay so that
brings us to these over here these are
the Audio Technica ath M50 BT
Bluetooth so they made a wireless
version finally of the famous m50s that
I've been a fan of for years and it's
exactly what it sounds like it's
literally a pair of m50s with the wire
snipped nothing too crazy or extra they
charge via micro USB they have a play
pause and media controls on the side and
you can still plug them in if you want
to and use them on a desktop overall
this is really just a Revival of a
classic for the 2018 situation we find
ourselves in the comfort is the same the
build and materials are the same they're
just still super flexible and adjustable
and the sound signature is the same
which is what I loved about these there
is no noise cancellation but the passive
noise isolation from the pads is pretty
great so this is an awesome pair of
casual listening headphones as the
previous m50s were but now they're
Wireless for your phone especially if
you don't need noise cancellation plus
these are way cheaper so I'll leave a
link to all this stuff talking about
down below now of course with all that
there is Fitness and working out I still
kind of consider these all a little
little too nice to wear while working
out plus I don't want to like have them
fall off and break so I still stick with
wireless earbuds for working out so you
might expect me to go directly to the
Jaybird run for wireless earbuds but
they're still not quite exactly what I
prefer they are pretty great for their
first pair of truly wireless earbuds as
they've done before they sound amazing
but in your ears there's still a little
bit clunky and a little bit heavy mostly
thanks to the batteries so for working
out and moving around and things like
that I still prefer the earbuds that
have the wire connecting them in the
back it doesn't bother me they're still
Wireless to my phone and I just feel
like they lock in my ear better they're
more comfortable so I still like these
Jaybird X3 has actually been my go-to
for a while I have multiple pairs they
sound great still they're super
lightweight they stay in my ears the
battery lasts forever for these tiny
little earbuds like eight hours straight
there's matte black or matte red or
whatever color you're into and they are
less expensive than the fully Wireless
versions so can't really ask for much
more than that the the Jaybird X4 has
come out since then they are a bit more
rugged and a bit more modern but they're
still not USBC in fact I actually find
them harder to charge so I haven't felt
the need to upgrade yet maybe there will
be a USBC version coming soon anyway
that's pretty much where we're at so far
for wireless headphones at least for me
on iPhone believe it or not airpods are
still sort of the go-to as far as
portability and convenience we've had
them in matte black in our store wink
wink but these These are easily some of
the most popular headphones or earbuds
now for iPhone that have ever existed
now there are also rumors of airpods too
like starting to pop up I'm not sure how
credible those are they seem pretty
early and I'm also not sure what would
be different about airpods 2 it may be
wireless charging but I'll keep an eye
on that and also I gotta mention I've
heard a lot about these Sony uh 1000 xm3
I think is what they're called they're
again the same price as the Bose and the
surface headphones I haven't tried them
yet but a lot of people seem to like
them so I may end up checking those out
too but so far this is what I found out
okay that's pretty much it all right as
a prize for making it to the end of the
video
I have a little bit of a an extra for
you we have a couple extra of the Audio
Technica athm 50 BT you get the little
early heads up that these will be in a
giveaway some will be on Instagram some
will be on Twitter so make sure you're
following in these two places over the
next week to get all the info for those
when they come out
that's pretty much it have a happy
holiday thanks again for watching talk
to you guys in the next one peace